ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BABY
BACKER FORGES RADFORD CABRERO
QUARTET THE DALLY DOG THEY'RE
AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTS BERG WEST O HER
TADO JONES CAN WATER LAYERED
FLAVOR THE MON THE CHOIR
MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN NIELSEN A
TOWBOAT TEN FOUR TWENTY NOW ROSS
RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY
KATHY WEINER WILKE. MEMBERS OF
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
REALM AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE THE DAY WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER BY SENATOR GONZALES AFTER
WHICH WILL ACTUALLY REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE BY SENATOR. ARTILLERY
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD HELP
ALL OF US TO BELIEVE IN THIS NEW
YEAR THAT IS GIVEN TO US ON
TOUCH. FULL OF THINGS THAT HAVE
NEVER BEEN FULL OF WORK THAT'S
NEVER BEEN DONE. FULL OF TASKS
CLAIMS AND DEMANDS. LET US KNOW
THE BLESSINGS THAT ACCOMPANY OUR
ATTEMPTS TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE
NECESSARY SIRIUS AND GREAT
THINGS. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME. I'M IN. CENTERS OF AGAIN
THIS YEAR LET US CONTINUE TO
HONOR THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM. AND AGAIN OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. PLEASE
PUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEART. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
. WHICH. MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NINE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WE'LL BE DOING READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DOING RAT. PARTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BEGIN READ IN
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
INTRODUCTIONS ARE FIRST READINGS
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AS
WALL. NOW MEMBERS REMOVING TWO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS
THIS IS THE TIME THAT IF YOU
HAVE ANY BILLS THAT YOU WANT
REMOVED FROM THERE THE FILE NOW
WAS THE TIME I SEE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SUPPRESSANT- FOR MATTERS
FIRST. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY.
TWENTY EIGHT. WHICH IS S. B.
FOUR FOUR FOUR HERTZBERG. TWO
FIVE ITEM EIGHTY THREE SP FOUR
FIFTY HERTZ BURKE AND THEN ON
BEHALF OF MR UMBER. NUMBER THREE
FILE AND NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE S.
P. THIRTY FOUR NUMBER. AND
LASTLY FOR FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT S. P. FORTY NINE- BERG
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
IT DOES NOT SENATOR LEVEL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
I'D LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM
EIGHT THIRTY ONE S. B. FIFTY
THREE FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU TO THE TEST WILL NOT
SINNERS CANNOT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I REQUEST PERMISSION
TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL. CLARIFYING THE INTENT
INTENT. OF MY BILL SB EIGHT FROM
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A BILL
PERTAINING TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
ACT. THANK YOU. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SENATOR WITH A MISSION
PLEASE REMOVE A FILE ITEM EIGHT
TWELVE SP SIX FIFTY SIX A MAN
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE A RETURN
TO THIRD READING. STUDENTS WILL
NOT THANK YOU. SECOND RING OKAY. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
. SENATE THIRD READING FIRST UP
IS ITEM TWENTY FOUR. BY SENATOR
DODD IS NOT HERE OKAY.
CARDMEMBERS REMOVING OUT TO FALL
IN TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
SKINNER CENTER CHANNEL HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATOR WINNER I'M SORRY
SENATOR WEAH. MAN CENTER PLEASE
RE. SENATE BILL ONE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO CALFRESH SOONER WE- I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I'M ALWAYS
HAPPY TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY- OUR
COLLEAGUES- SP ONE OF SEVEN-
SIXTY INCREASE CALFRESH
ENROLLMENT ACCESSIBILITY- BY
REMOVING. BARRIERS TO ENROLLMENT
pRATES OF PARTICIPATION- IN THE
FEDERAL SNAP PROGRAM AND WE NEED
TO MAKE IT EASIER AND FASTER FOR
PEOPLE- PARTICULARLY SENIORS AND
PEOPLE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES-
TO SIGN UP- FOR CALFRESH- THIS
BILL WILL HELP DO THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEN NINE AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE I'M TWENTY
EIGHT. ALAN ARCHULETA FIVE
ADKINS. FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER
FORTIVE FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY
AROUND. CORTEZ HI SALLY. DOT
THEY'RE AWESOME I A COMMON. I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROW. HERZ
BERG HI WEAR A HYPER TANTO I
JONES I CAN LONGER LAYERED.
LLEVA HI THE MON I MCGUIRE YEAH.
HI MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI PAM
FIVE FORTINO FIVE ROCK I RUBIO.
I SKINNER FIVE STERN HI AMBER
WHITE HOUSE V. FIVE WINNER I
WILL. I'M SICK TO PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. ALAN FACTOR. BY
ADAM. DALLY I. DOT I GLAZER
GROVE I. CAN LONGER LEHRER.
NUMBER WELL. FOUR I USE THIRTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE NUMBERS REMOVED ON THE
FILE I'M TWENTY NINE FOR SENATOR
WIENER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
FOUR BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING CENTER
WINNER FORGERS I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AS B. TWO
THIRTY FOUR- WILL- ADDRESSES A
CRITICAL NEED IN OUR STATE WHICH
IS THE NEED TO INCREASE HOUSING
FOR OUR MOST AT RISK. TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH YOUTH EXITING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM YOU FOR
EXITING THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND USE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE YOU ARE AT
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
AND WE DO NOT DO NEARLY ENOUGH
TO SUPPORT THEM- AND TO HELP GET
THEM INTO A STABLE ENVIRONMENTS-
SP TWO THIRTY FOUR WILL CREATE
A- REVOLVING OR A LOAN PROGRAM.
A FORGIVABLE LOAN PROGRAM- SO
THAT A HOUSING ARE SPECIFIC TO
OUR WRISTS TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
I CAN BE FUNDED AND BUILT- AND
WE CAN SUPPORT- THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IDOL. THANK YOU ANY FOR
DISCUSS OR THE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IN
NINETEEN NINETY MEMBERS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ON THIS
MEASURE. YOU'RE NINETY NINE OZ
THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR- SO HOW DO YOU GET FORTY.
OUR MEMBERS WERE MOVINGTO FALL
ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR DODD
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
MEASURE HE IS MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE GOD AN ACT RELATING
TO WILDLIFE. SENATOR DR. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THE%
BIG GAME MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY TEN THIS
IS THE COUNT GENERATED FROM
HUNTING TAGS TO BE USED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF HUNDREDS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IT'S BEEN USED TO FUND
BOTH NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE
PROJECTS. HOWEVER AN INTERNAL
AUDIT OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
FINDINGS DECLARED THEIR READING
OF THE STATUTE IS ONLY ALLOWING
CONTRACTS WITH NON PROFIT
ENTITIES PRIOR TO THE AUDIT
CONTRACTS WITH PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT ENTITIES ALLOWED FOR SUCH
IN DEVERS AS AERIAL SURVEYS
THESE PROJECTS ARE CRITICAL TO
THE WORK OF THE BIG GAME MANAGED
TO GET OUT. AND IT'S WHAT IT WAS
DESIGNED FOR SP THREE SEVENTY
PROVIDES A SIMPLE A SIMPLE
CLARIFICATION STATING THE FUNDS
FOR THE BIG GAME MANAGER TO GET
OUT CAN BE USED FOR PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ENTITIES INCLUDING
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED INDIAN
TRIBES THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIGHT. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. YOU'RE NINETY NINE
OZ THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON THE FILE I'M TWENTY FIVE THAT
SENATOR DODD AGAIN. HE'S
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MARIE
SENT A BILL TO SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS CENTER
DOT. THANK YOU AGAIN MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS EVERY YEAR 55%
OF LICENSE CONTRACTORS CLAIM TO
HAVE NO EMPLOYEES AND FILE FOR
EXEMPTION FROM HAVING WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE WITH THE
CONTRACTOR'S LICENSE STATE
LICENSE BOARD. HOWEVER THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
OWN RESEARCH AND ENFORCEMENT
CASE DATA DEMONSTRATES THAT MANY
CONTRACTORS ARE FALSELY MAKING
THAT CLAIM. S. B. TWO SIXTEEN
WILL HELP PROTECT WORKERS IT
WILL PRECLUDE THE FILING OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION EXEMPTIONS
FOR CONCRETE HVAC AND TREE
SERVICE CONTRACTORS AND BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WILL BE
CAUGHT WILL WE BE REQUIRED OF
ALL CONTRACTORS TO MAINTAIN
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE.
THE SYSTEMATIC THE SKEWS ME THE
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM OF CONTRACTORS
CLAIMING EXEMPTION EVEN WHILE
HAVING EMPLOYEES HAS LED TO
UNFAIR INCREASES IN WORKERS
COMPENSATION FOR COMPLIANT
CONTRACTOR EMPLOYEES EXPOSING
WORKERS ANY RUMORS. THE FISCAL
AND FINANCIAL RISKS IT IS NOT
FAIR TO OTHER EMPLOYEES AT TWO
OTHER EMPLOYERS THAT ARE DOING-
THIS- LEGITIMATELY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE IN
NINETEEN NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
AUDIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX. HEARINGS YES
SENATOR BATES. YEAH THERE'S AN
OBJECTION TO UNITED BROKAW
SENATOR BATES. OKAY MEMBER
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
ISSUE. ALAN ARCHULETA HI ADKINS
I FACE. BACKER FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM WE'RE
TESTING FIVE DALLY. DOT I
TORONTO I A GUNMAN I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
WHERE SO FIVE FOR TORONTO HI
JONES. CAMCORDER LAYERED LLEVA.
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
I MEN FIVE NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN
FIVE UNTIL ABOUT. FIVE TEN FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA. HI RALPH I REVIEW
HI SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER. I WILL. I'M SECURE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
. ALAN BAIT. BACKER FOR JUST.
HAVE I EVER. DALLY GLAZER GROVE
. JONES FIVE. CAN LONGER LAYERED
NUMBER WELL. MARCH TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM. NUMBER THAT'S. PHYLUM
TO GUARD. BUT WHERE DID. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX.
FOLLOWING TWENTY SIX CENTER DOT
. I'M SECTOR PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO MEDI CAL
CENTER DOT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP SEVEN ONE
SEVEN WILL HELP ENSURE ACCESS
FOR MEDICARE RECIPIENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO DEPEND ON
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT REFERRED
TO AS COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY
OR C. R. T. TO MEET THE UNIQUE
MEDICAL PHYSICAL AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS. S. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN
PROTECTS CRITICAL ACCESS TO C.
R. G. BY CONFORMING C. R. T.
CODES THE CURRENT FEDERAL
STANDARDS IN CLINICAL BEST
PRACTICES IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
H. C. S. TO CONSIDER THE
RESOURCE INTENSIVE DELIVERY
MODEL C. R. T. IN ESTABLISHING
FUTURE PAYMENT RATES. THESE
CHANGES TO HELP PROTECT ACCESS
TO SPECIAL C. R. T. PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES ARE OFTEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN INDIVIDUAL
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY OR IN MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE FACILITY BASED
CARE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM IN NINETEEN NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE NATURAL
CALL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. IN
NINETEEN NINE ALL EYES THIRTY
TWO MILLS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOWING TWENTY SEVEN
AGAIN SENATOR DODD. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY MAY
READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT NUTRITION SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
YES B. TWENTY WILL HELP TO
SECURE CALFRESH BENEFITS FOR AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE BUT SIMPLY UNAWARE
OF THEIR ELIGIBILITY NEARLY ONE
IN THREE COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA FACE FOOD INSECURITY
WITH BLACK AND HISPANIC STUDENTS
MORE LIKELY THAN OTHERS TO FACE
FOOD INSECURITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN NINETEEN
NINE MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FOLLOWING
TWENTY SEVEN. HERE IN JINAN ALL
EYES THIRTY TWO. NOES ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SENATE THIRD
READING OUR GOING TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SOON REQUIRE
REPAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT HAPPY NEW YEAR AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WILL BE
MEETING IN FIFTEEN MINUTES IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. GOVERNING FINANCIAL
MEETING FIFTEEN MINUTES FROM
ROOM FORTY TWO ALL THREE MEMBERS
OUR MOVIE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS NOW IS THE TIME FOR
JOURNEY MEMORIES WE HAVE OUR
JOURNEY MEMORIES. PREPARED WE
WILL START WITH SENATOR SCANNER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS ONE IS REALLY HARD FOR ME.
WE ON MONDAY WE- MANY OF YOU
SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY ABOUT A
LONG TERM STAFF MEMBER WHO YOU
KNOW IS STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW
WITH CANCER. AND HE AND HIS
FAMILY I THINK WE'RE ABLE TO
ENJOY AND ENJOY MAYBE IS NOT AT
LEAST FEEL THE RESPECT THAT THE
INSTITUTION GAVE HIM BECAUSE HE
WAS ABLE TO HEAR IT FROM US.
WHILE HE WAS STILL WITH US. HI
WE DON'T HAVE THAT PRIVILEGE
TODAY. AND NEITHER DOES GABE
CASWELL OR HIS FAMILY. BECAUSE
GABE CASWELL A LONG TERM STAFFER
OF THIS INSTITUTION AND
CONSULTANT TO BOTH THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
. TRAGICALLY DIED THIS FALL
UNEXPECTEDLY AND HE WAS YOUNG.
HE HAD A HEART CONDITION HE WAS
AWARE OF BUT IT WAS NOT
CONSIDERED TO BE. WE DIDN'T
EXPECT GABE TO PASS UNEXPECTEDLY
. EVERYONE WHO KNEW GABE CASWELL
KNEW HIS DEEP WARMTH AND LOVE
GABE HAD A FAMILY OUT OF STATE
BUT HERE LOCALLY HE HAD A CHOSEN
FAMILY. AND HE ADORED DOT FAMILY
ESPECIALLY HIS KIDS WHO HE
PARENTED AS IF THEY WERE HIS
OWN. AND HE TREATED HIS FRIENDS
LIKE FAMILY AND HIS COLLEAGUES
IN HERE IN THE BUILDING. WHETHER
YOU WERE A LEGISLATOR ADVOCATE
STAFF GAVE TREATED YOU WITH
RESPECT AND ACCEPTANCE
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER HE HAD A
DIFFERING OPINION ABOUT THE BILL
YOU WERE PITCHING WHERE THE
ISSUE YOU'RE ADVOCATING. AND
CONSEQUENTLY EVERYONE WHO WORKED
WITH HIM LOVED HIM I GAVE.
DURING THE FOUR YEARS THAT I
CHAIRED THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE I NEVER GOT A CALL OF
COMPLAINT ABOUT GABE AND- IN
THAT COMMITTEE. I FIRST MET GABE
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
HE WAS STAFF TO THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I
WAS ON THAT COMMITTEE. LIKE SO
MANY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CHAIR
TOM- YANO ALSO LEFT GAVE. ANY
POSTED MANY TIMES AFTER GABE'S
DEATH. AND ONE OF HIS POSTS
DESCRIBE GAVE AS A LOVING AND
PROUD GAY FATHER GREAT MINDS AND
GREAT SPIRIT. GABE WAS A DEAR
FRIEND AND MENTOR TO STAFF
THROUGHOUT THIS BUILDING
ESPECIALLY SOME OF MY PERSONAL
STAFF AND HE WAS VERY CARING
TOWARDS HIS PUBLIC SAFETY
FELLOWS. ALWAYS WILLING TO
EXPLAIN COMPLEX PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES OR HELP A COLLEAGUE OR
LEGISLATOR WITH BILL DEVELOPMENT
HE LOVED TO THIS INSTITUTION AND
EVERYONE IN IT HOW MANY OF OUR
STAFF TELL YOU ALMOST DAILY THAT
THEY LOVE COMING TO WORK. HE
ALWAYS WANTED AND WAS WILLING TO
TAKE ON THE HARDEST BILL'S
REFORMS OTHERS WERE FREE TO TAKE
ON. THE HOT POTATOES THAT IS WE
SAY COULD BURN YOU. BUT HAD
THOSE POT POTATOES HAD THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON IMPROVING
JUSTICE AND IMPROVING PEOPLE'S
LIVES WHETHER IT WAS THE SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY POLICE ISSUES
ARE SO MUCH MORE. EVERY MAJOR
POLICE REFORM PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT IS PASSED IN
THE LAST DECADE. GABE WAS
PROHIBITIVELY INVOLVED. FANS
EVEN THOUGH THESE WERE REFORMS
HE HAD THE RESPECT OF THE VERY
ENTITIES THAT USUALLY. A POST
THOSE- BILLS ANY HAD AN OPEN
DIALOGUE WITH THEM AND SO YOU
REALLY COULD IT ALLOWED PEOPLE
LIKE ME WHO CARRIED THOSE
COMPLEX BILLS TO BE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH BECAUSE
THERE WAS TRUST. BETWEEN THE
ENTITIES EVEN WHEN THEY OPPOSE
THE BILLS AND IT WAS BECAUSE OF
GABE'S RELATIONSHIP HE HELPED
THREAD THE NEEDLE ON DIFFICULT
ISSUES HE BALANCE DUE PROCESS
WITH ACCOUNTABILITY AND HE MADE
SURE THAT THE VOICES OF IT
IMPACTED PEOPLE. WERE HURT. HE
WAS A STRAIGHT SHOOTER HE ALWAYS
SPOKE THE TRUTH BUT HE BROUGHT
LEVITY TO EVERYTHING. TO EVERY
NEGOTIATION HIS COMEDIC TIMING
AND HIS PLAYFUL SARCASM WAS
IMMEDIATELY DISARMING. HIS LAUGH
WAS INFECTIOUS AND ANY OF YOU
WHO WERE IN IS TEXTING CIRCLING
HIS TEXTS WERE LEGENDARY YOU
KNOW HE WAS QUICK WITH THE FUNNY
MEMES. AS SOME OTHER PEOPLE
AROUND HERE ARE BUT HE WAS
REALLY QUICK WITH THEM. THIS IS
THE KIND OF MESSAGE THAT I
RECEIVED FROM COUNTLESS PEOPLE
WHO WORKED WITH GAVE PERMISSION
TO READ. WITHOUT OBJECTION. I
MISS HIM SO MUCH I THINK ABOUT
HIS LAUGH EVERY DAY SOMETIMES BY
JUST REPLAY VIDEO WITH HIS
LAUGHTER BECAUSE IT'S SO
INFECTIOUS I'M HONORED THAT WE
GOT TO DO THE GROUND BREAKING
WORK THAT WE DID TOGETHER I WILL
BE TALKING ABOUT THE WORK WE
ACCOMPLISHED AND I REMEMBER IT
FONDLY FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE
THAT WAS A STAFF MEMBER WHO
WORKED WITH HIM IN THE PAST.
GABE'S LEGACY LIVES ON THROUGH
THE WORK HE HAS DONE TO PROVIDE
COUNTLESS PEOPLE SECOND CHANCES.
AND IN A SPECIFIC SITUATION THAT
COMES TO MIND. GAMES WORK IS
DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RE
SENTENCING AND RELEASE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS NOW A NEW
PARENT. AND AS A THRIVING MEMBER
OF THE COMMUNITY. THAT NEW LIFE
THAT BABY BORN FROM THE
SITUATION IS A PART OF GABE'S
LEGACY. CABLE LIVE ON IN SO MANY
OF OUR HEARTS HE IS TRULY LOVED
AND WILL BE MISSED FOREVER.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO WANT TO JOIN
SENATOR SKINNER AND RECOGNIZING
- GABRIEL CASWELL WHO AS SHE
STATED WAS AMAZING STAFFER AND I
WAS HONORED TO WORK WITH HIM IN
MIND. LAST YEAR SERVING AS CHAIR
OF PUBLIC SAFETY. GAVE AS HE'S
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN BY MANY OF
US HERE WAS BORN TO THE LATE
DENNIS CASWELL. IN THE LATE
CHRISTOPHER GATLIN AND JULY
TWENTY SIXTH NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX. GAVE WAS A LOVING SON
PARTNER BROTHER FRIEND AND
FATHER FIGURE TO TWO YOUNG BOYS
MATHWORLD ON. HE WAS ABIT
SEMINOLES FANS WHERE HE
GRADUATED WITH HIS DEGREE FROM
FLORIDA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
EARNED HIS LAW DEGREE FROM
GOLDEN STATE UNIVERSITY. GAVE
STARTED HIS CAREER HERE IN THIS
BUILDING AND ASSEMBLY SIDE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN. AND HE
WORKED THERE UNTIL HE JOINED THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND- TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
GABE WAS IN ITS EXCEPTIONAL
PUBLIC SERVICE. AND ONE OF A
KIND INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS
RESPECTED AND LOVED BY MANY. IN
AND OUT OF THIS BUILDING. HE WAS
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR JUSTICE AS
SENATOR SKINNER STATED HE NEVER
SHIED AWAY. FROM SHARING HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE ISSUES THAT
MATTER MOST TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
. HE WORKED ON SOME OF THE
BIGGEST AND MOST CRITICAL
LEGISLATION TO GO TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. MOST RECENTLY GAVEWAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN WORKING ON
SENATOR SKINNER'S BILL ON POLICE
TRANSPARENCY- SP FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE AND ON I. S. B. SIXTEEN.
YEAH AND ALSO WORKED JOINTLY
WITH ME AND MY STAFF ON LAST
YEAR'S PLEASED TO CERTIFICATION
AS FREE TO. AND I REMEMBER LAST
MAY- SHORTLY BEFORE AS OUR
SENATOR PROBES SUSPENSE HEARING
WE WERE TRYING TO WORK OUT
AMENDMENTS HONESTY TO THE MAKE
SURE WE WERE ABLE TO GET IT TO
THE FLOOR. AND IT WAS FIVE
O'CLOCK AND I WAS IN THE ROOM
WITH THE PT- PRETTY I CONSIDER
HURTS BIRDS CAN EARN TEN
DOLLARS. AND WE HAD BEEN TALKING
AND STRUGGLING WITH A WAY TO
FIND A WAY TO MOVE THIS BILL
FOR. AND AFTER IDEA AFTER IDEA
OF NOTHING REALLY WORKED AND SO-
I THINK WAS SENATORS KENNEDY
SAID LET'S CALL GAVE. AND HE WAS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A SOCCER GAME-
WHAT IS SUN AND IT. LIKE WITHIN
TEN MINUTES SHE CAME UP WITH
IDEA FOR US TO CONSIDER. AND IT
WAS THE IDEA OF THAT HE BROUGHT
FORTH. THE MATE TO BILL POSSIBLE
WE TOOK UP THE VERY NEXT DAY AND
HELP GET THE VOTES WE NEEDED. TO
MAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR. DELEGATE
WHO DID THAT. WITHOUT IT WITHOUT
A HEADS UP NOTICE ANYTHING THAT
AT ALL. ALL WALL AGAIN ATTENDING
HER SON'S SOCCER GAME. THAT'S
THE KIND OF PERSON GABE WAS.
ALWAYS HARD WORKING ALWAYS
AVAILABLE ALWAYS LOOKING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING ALWAYS LOOKING
TO. BE A TEAM PLAYER. HE WAS
INCREDIBLY BRIGHT. COMPASSIONATE
AND GENEROUS. GABLE WAS A
COLLEAGUE AND DEAR FRIEND TO
MANY STAFF WHO WORKED WITH HIM
IN PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES HE WAS
ALSO INCREDIBLE MENTOR TO MANY
OF THE YOUNG FOLKS ESPECIALLY
THE SENATE FELLOWS- THAT HE HELD
DEAR AND NEAR AND DEAR TO THE
OMINOUS HEART GATE WAS RESPECTED
BY ALL CAME TO KNOWN MEMBERS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ALIKE IT DIDN'T
MATTER WHAT SIDE OF THE ISSUE
YOU'RE WRONG GAVE TALKED WITH
EVERYBODY AND RESPECTED EVERYONE
HE PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY AND
OCTOBER AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
FORTY FIVE AND HE'S LEFT A
TREMENDOUS VOID NOT ONLY IN
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT IN THIS
BUILDING MONKS ARE SAFE MEMBERS
AS WELL AS STAFF. BUT HE ALSO
LEFT A REMARKABLE LEGACY THAT'S
MADE CALIFORNIA SAFER BETTER AND
FAIRER TO ALL BABY SURVIVED BY
AUSTIN ALL OVER CAMILLE ANDREW
AND WARREN SULLIVAN AND THEIR
PARENTS STEPHANIE AND DAVID
SULLIVAN AS WELL AS MANY FRIENDS
COLLEAGUES AND FAMILIES. WHO ARE
WATCHING NOW ONLINE THANK YOU
FOR SHARING DATA WITH US. WITH
STATE. HE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF GABRIEL
CASWELL. THE CENTRE BRADFORD
SUNDERLAND AS- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- MY COMMENTS WILL BE
BRIEF BUT I DO WANT TO JOIN IN
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND EXPRESS
THE SADNESS THAT WE ARE FEELING
ABOUT THE PASSING OF GAME CASTLE
I'M I FIRST MET HIM- WHEN I GOT
TO THE ASSEMBLY AND I WAS
ASSIGNED TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND THE FIRST HEARING
. I DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT HIT
ME I MEAN LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY IN THE BILLS THAT WERE
BEING HEARD I WAS KIND OF
SHOCKED. BY WHAT I WAS HEARING.
AND AT ONE POINT DURING THE
HEARING A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK
I GOT UP TO GO- USE THE RESTROOM
AND JUST SORT OF. SHAKING MY
HEAD AT WHAT I WAS HEARING AND
AS I WALKED BY GABE. HE HAD THIS
BIG SILLY GRIN ON HIS FACE AND
HE SAID. WELCOME TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND I THOUGHT OH OKAY
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHO HE WAS I
DIDN'T. KNOW IS MY FIRST HEARING
I DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WORKED FOR
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS I HAD NO
IDEA I JUST KNOW THAT. HE WAS
VERY FRIENDLY. AND OVER THE
YEARS THAT I SERVED ON THE
COMMITTEE HE WAS VERY VERY
HELPFUL HE DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE.
THAT YOUR IDEALS DIDN'T ALIGN
WITH HIS HE WAS THERE. TO BE
HELPFUL AND I AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT AND HE DID.
HAVE A VERY- WRY SENSE OF HUMOR
THAT IS FOR SURE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED IN THIS BUILDING SO.
I DO WANNA EXTEND MY CONDOLENCES
TO HIS FRIENDS. AND HIS FAMILY
AND EVERYBODY WHO LOVES HIM- I
IT WAS A SHOCK TO HEAR THAT HE
HAD PASSED AND- HE WILL BE
MISSED THANK YOU. I THANK
SENATOR MELINDA'S CENTER WINNER. THAT THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
BUT THIS IS- ONE OF THE
SITUATIONS WHEN I WHEN I LEARNED
THAT DAVID PAST I JUST I WAS
ABSOLUTELY SPEECHLESS I JUST
COULDN'T. I BELIEVE IT NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW HE'S YOUNG-
YOU KNOW HE'S A GOOD DAD I JUST.
WANTED SOME WONDERFUL HUMAN
BEING AND IT'S JUST IT'S AN
INDESCRIBABLE TRAGEDY- TO LOSE
HIM BOTH FOR HIS FAMILY AND HIS
COMMUNITY- BUT ALSO- FOR THE
SENATE. I'VE HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE SINCE I. JOINED THE
CENTER- THE END OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN- AND IT'S ONE OF THOSE
COMMITTEES WHERE NOT THAT MANY
MEMBERS ARE ARE LIKE EAGER TO
SERVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S NOT
AN OVERSUBSCRIBED- COMMITTEE
LIKE SOME COMMITTEES ARE- YOU'VE
BEEN TO THE POINT WHERE THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY SHRUNK IN
SIZE- THIS YEAR. BUT IT'S AN
UNBELIEVABLY IMPORTANT-
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF THE WORK
IT DOES AROUND INCARCERATION THE
PRISON SYSTEM AROUND POLICING
AROUND PAROLE AROUND SO MANY
ISSUES THAT IMPACT MILLIONS OF
LIVES- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT COMMUNITY ISSUES THAT
COME BEFORE. THE COMMITTEE ARE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHEN
CRIMES ARE COMMITTED. YOU KNOW
THERE IS THE PERSON COMMITTING A
CRIME THERE IS A VICTIM THERE'S
THE COMMUNITY DOES THE BIG
PICTURE OF ONE OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. SHOULD LOOK LIKE
AND THESE ARE ISSUES WHERE WERE
EVERYONE FALLS- THERE THERE.
IT'S JUST INCREDIBLY- IT'S JUST
A REALLY REALLY- INTENSE
COMMITTEE. I AM A ONE OF THE
THINGS I APPRECIATE ABOUT ALL OF
THE STAFF ON OUR SIMPLE SAFETY
COMMITTEE I'M PARTICULARLY GAVE
AS THEIR ABILITY TO US TO
PROVIDE US WITH WITH UNBIASED.
HISTORY FOR ANALYSIS AND THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN THERE ARE BILLS
WERE YOU JUST YOU JUST UNSURE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
BILL. AND YOU. CAN ALWAYS GO TO
GAVE A HUGE AS YOU KNOW HE HE
WAS VERY VERY PROGRESSIVE. GUY
BUT HE WAS GIVE YOU THIS FOR.
BOTH SIDES. AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION YOU
NEED TO AND HE UNDERSTOOD WHAT
HIS ROLE WAS. I ALWAYS
APPRECIATED BY. I ALSO HE HE- I
WILL JUST SAY THAT AS A GAME
MAN- THERE THAT D. YOU KNOW
UNDERSTOOD THE SPECIFIC. HARMS
THAT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
HAS INFLICTED ON LGBTQ PEOPLE
THE CRIMINALIZATION. OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND REMOVE SOME REALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT BILLS AROUND
HIV DECRIMINALIZATION AND
REFORMING THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY. THESE ARE NOT
POLITICAL WINNER KIND OF BILLS
SEASON ON BILLS WHERE YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A PARADE AND PUBLIC
OPINION IS GOING TO BE ON YOUR
SIDE. BUT THESE WERE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
AND GAVE AS A GAME AND GOD IT-
AND WAS THERE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND COUNSEL- ANNALS FOREVER BE
APPRECIATIVE FOR JUST EVERYTHING
ABOUT HIM AND I AM. TO HIS
FAMILY I AM SO SORRY THAT THIS
HAPPENED- ANSWERS PLEASE NO BAGS
THIS IS THE WORST IS SO BELOVED
IN THIS BUILDING- AND THE REST
IN PEACE. THANK YOU HAHA HOUSE
THAT THE NAME BE BROUGHT FORWARD
SO WE CAN PROPERLY MORE ALLIES.
AND THIS IS WHAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT JUST A FEW WORDS
ALTHOUGH I DID NOT KNOW HIM
WELL- MY STAFF KNEW HIM WELL THE
MY STUFF THE LAST OF THAT IF WE
COULD SAY IF I COULD SAY A FEW
WORDS ON THEIR BEHALF BECAUSE
THEY KNEW HIM SO WELL ABOUT HOW
HE- TREATED OUR ISSUES AS THE
AND OUR WORK IS TRANSFORMATIVE-
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS TO. TO THE
TO THE STATE AND ESPECIALLY AND
NO MATTER WHAT THE OUTCOME HE
WAS ALWAYS THERE TO ENCOURAGE
OTHERS WHEN MY PUBLIC SAFETY
BILLS FACE DIFFICULT VOTES GABE
REACHED OUT HE REACHED OUT TO
HELP AND ESPECIALLY AFTER ONE
HARD VOTE HE SAID. REMEMBER THE
LONG GAME. SO NO DOUBT GABE'S
LEGACY IS GOING TO BE A GUIDING
LIGHT AND I SO TRULY APPRECIATE
WHAT HE HAS DONE. FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO ON BEHALF OF MY
STAFF AND OTHERS WHOSE LIVES HE
TOUCHED MY SINCEREST CONDOLENCES
. THANK YOU AS STATED HE WILL BE
SORELY MISSED BY NOT ONLY THE
SENATE BUT BY THIS INSTITUTION
AS A WHOLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE'LL **** MAY BE
BROUGHT FORTH AND BE PROBABLY
MORE LINES EXCEPTION- GARAGE SO
YOU HAVE A- JURY MEMBER.
PRESIDENT I RISE TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF TWO SURVIVORS OF THE
INFAMOUS. EL MONTE GARMENT
SLAVERY CASE. IS ONE OF THE MOST
RECOGNIZED MODERN CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SLAVERY SEVENTY
TWO THAI NATIONALS WERE FOUND
LIVING AND MAKING GARMENTS
AMONGST HORRIFIC CONDITIONS IN A
MAKESHIFT GARMENT FACTORY WITHIN
A RESIDENTIAL DUPLEX. THE
WORKERS MOST OF THEM WOMEN HAD
BEEN HELD CAPTIVE BEHIND FENCES
TOPPED WITH RAZOR WIRE AND FULL
FORCE TO SO GARMENTS SIXTEEN
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
THE TWO SURVIVORS WHO RECENTLY
PASSED HAD SINCE GONE ON TO LEAD
FULFILLING LIVES DESPITE THIS
DARK CHAPTER. FIRST TIME NEON
THOMAS WHO PASSED AWAY IN
SEPTEMBER AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
FOUR HE WAS KNOWN AS AN INK-
OPTIMISTIC PERSON WHOSE SPIRIT
WAS INFECTIOUS AND BROUGHT LIGHT
TO ANY SITUATION. HER OWN WORDS
REFLECT HOW SHE MAINTAINS THAT
MAINTAIN SUCH A POSITIVE OUTLOOK
ON LIFE WHAT'S FOUND WITHIN THE
EL MONTE TYING GARMENTS SLAVERY
CASE EXHIBIT AT THE MUSEUM OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE QUOTE. I SEE SO
MUCH BEAUTY THERE IS SO MUCH
BEAUTIFUL HERE IN THE WORLD THE
DARKNESS HAS PASSED AND QUOTE
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY SHE WAS
ALSO REGARDED FOR HER AMAZING
GARDENING AND SEWING SKILLS. AND
THE BENEFIT OF HER FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS BECAUSE THEY HAD A
VIBRANT FARM OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES BEAUTIFUL QUILTS
PILLOWCASES AND CLOTHING. OF
WHICH SOME ARTICLES ARE ALSO ON
DISPLAY AT THE MUSEUM OF
TOLERANCE. CHAMPION IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND AND RETIRED
SOCIAL WORKER JOSEPH ALONG WITH
HER TWO SONS. SECOND IS LAW ON
THE BIAS ONE FORTUNATELY JUST
PASSED AS WELL DESPITE HAVING
SUFFERED FROM DEPRESSION LONG
WAS ALSO KNOWN FOR BEING FUN AND
THE POSITIVE ENERGY SHE CREATED
WITHIN HER COMMUNITY HAVING
COMMITTED HER LIFE TO OTHERS.
SHE WAS A LOVING AND DEVOTED
MOTHER AND WIFE TO HER HUSBAND
JEFF AND YOUNG SON. THEIR LEGACY
OF COURAGE AND HOPE ARE
REMEMBERED AND WILL ENDEAR
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
BEYOND. THEIR HORRIFIC
EXPERIENCE CONTRIBUTED TO
RAISING THE ISSUE OF MODERN DAY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND MODERN DAY
SLAVERY. THEY FOUGHT FOR
THEMSELVES AND ALSO FOR REFORMS
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY DOES END
SWEATSHOP ABUSES. BECAUSE OF
THEIR DEDICATION TO CHANGING THE
SYSTEM THE TV SET WAS INTRODUCED
TO GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS A NEW TOOL TO HELP
PROSECUTE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS. OUR
DEEPEST AND PRINT THE
CONDOLENCES TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND LOVED ONES MER SISTERS REST
IN POWER YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR WORLD HAVE MADE THIS A
BETTER PLACE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO ASKED THAT YOU
BRING THOSE NAMES FOR IT SO IT
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR WIENER. IN
ORDER PREPARE FOR YOUR JOURNEY
NUMBER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
OUR COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ASK THAT
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF MARINE- TURKLE ROACH A MARINE
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT HOME
ON SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SURROUNDED BY
HER FAMILY AND ALL THE LOVE IN
THE WORLD SHE WAS SEVENTY SIX
YEARS OLD. AS A BRAVE YOUNG
WOMAN OF AGE OF NINETEEN- MARINE
LEFT HER NATIVE ENGLAND IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR AND FOLLOWED
HER DREAM TO COME TO AMERICA.
WHEN SHE ARRIVED SHE KNEW SHE
WAS HOME. NOT LONG AFTER COMING
TO YOU US BOTH OF HER PARENTS
PASSED AWAY. BY THREE OF HER
FOUR SIBLINGS SOON FOLLOWED HER
TO THE STATES MARINO TWO
DAUGHTERS JUSTINE AND SUZY-
SUSIE. LOFTIS IS A PERSONAL
FRIEND OF MINE. A MARINE BECAME
A PROUD NATURALIZED CITIZEN
RELOCATED TO SAN FRANCISCO. TO
RAISE HER GIRLS AS A DEVOTED
SINGLE MOM. IN SAN FRANCISCO SHE
SERVED AS THE FIRST DIRECTOR OF
PATIENT RELATIONS AT MOUNT ZION
HOSPITAL AND DISTINGUISHED
HERSELF AS A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
THOSE IN NEED- SHE TOOK HER
DAUGHTERS TO RALLIES AND MARCHES
IN GOLDEN GATE PARK. OFFERS FOR
THE PASSAGE OF THE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT. THEN FOR RESOURCES TO
FIGHT HIV AIDS PANDEMIC. AND
EVENTUALLY BRING HER
GRANDCHILDREN TO RALLIES AND THE
GENOCIDE IN DARFUR. AND ADVOCATE. FOR THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT. MARINA IS PRECEDED IN
DEATH BY HER LOVING HUSBAND
THOMAS TURKA AND SURVIVED BY HER
DAUGHTERS JUSTINE AND SUSIE HER
SONS IN LAW DENNIS AND TOM. HER
URSULA SHEILA AND GERALDINE- HER
BROTHER MALACHY HER.
GRANDCHILDREN JAMIE JORDAN CODY-
MARINE VIVIENNE AND GRACE HER
GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER OPINION ROSE
AND HER NIECES AND NEPHEWS
YOU'RE A HELL AND- JEANINE
EDDIE- AND ROBBIE AND LIVES- SHE
IS. ONE WONDERFUL WONDERFUL
HUMAN BEINGS I ASKED THE SENATE. ADJOURNED- IN HER MEMORY. I
THINK YOU WERE SHIPPING FOR ONE
CAN MEMORIALIZE. MISH TURK FOR
RUSSIA- NOW WE'RE MOVING TO.
CENTERS CAN HELP. MEMBERS IT IS
THE DEEP SADNESS THAT I ASKED
THE SENATE TO ADJOURN TODAY. IN
MEMORY OF A GOOD FRIEND
TRAILBLAZING PUBLIC OFFICIAL
LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
A FORMER STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WILMA CHAN. WILMA. DIED
TRAGICALLY ON NOVEMBER THIRD SHE
WAS ONLY SEVENTY TWO. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER PARTNER TWO
CHILDREN AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN.
LIKE SO MANY PEDESTRIANS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR IN THE LAST
ONE WAS STRUCK BY A CAR SHE WAS
IN A CROSSWALK SHE WAS WALKING
NEAR HER HOME ALONG THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA'S WATERFRONT WITH HER
BELOVED DOG MAGGIE WHEN SHE WAS
HIT AND KILLED. IT WAS ANOTHER
VERY VERY UNEXPECTED TRAGEDY FOR
THIS FALL. WILMA WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT PROTECTING CIVIL RIGHTS
AND EXPANDING HEALTH CARE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO
COULDN'T AFFORD IT SHE WAS ALSO
PASSIONATE ABOUT SAFEGUARDING
FAMILIES FROM POLLUTION THAT IS
ALL TOO COMMON IN LOCAL LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. SHE WAS
BORN TO CHINESE IMMIGRANTS IN
BOSTON SHE ATTENDED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THEN RECEIVED HER
BACHELOR'S FROM WELLESLEY
COLLEGE. SHE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
AFTER HER UNDERGRAD DEGREE AND
EARNED A MASTER'S IN
ADMINISTRATION AT STANFORD IN
POLICY ANALYSIS. AND THEN SHE
LAUNCHED HER REMARKABLE PUBLIC
SERVICE CAREER SHE FIRST STARTED
AS A AN ELECTED MEMBER OF THE
OAKLAND SCHOOL BOARD SHE WAS
THEN ELECTED TO THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND SHE
HELD THAT POSITION UNTIL SHE RAN
FOR THE LEGISLATURE BUT SHE
RETURNED BACK TO THE COUNTY
AFTER BEING TURNED OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. LIKE MANY OF THE
SEATS THAT WOMAN BENCHLEY HELD.
HE WAS THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
ON THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SOUPS SHE WENT ON THEN TO SERVE
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX. AND SHE BECAME THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN MAJORITY LEADER.
AND SHATTERED THE ASSEMBLY'S
GLASS CEILING BY BECOMING THE
FIRST WOMAN MAJORITY LEADER.
OVER THE YEARS SHE GAINED A
REPUTATION FOR BEING A
RELENTLESS NO NONSENSE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATE TORE. WHO
WORKED TIRELESSLY BEHIND THE
SCENES TO GET HER BILLS ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE. SHE ONCE
REMARKED TO A JOURNALIST ABOUT
HER POLITICAL STYLE BECAUSE IF
YOU DID A GOOGLE SEARCH ON OR
YOU DON'T SEE A LOT OF QUOTES
FROM A LOT ARTICLE SHE WAS NOT A
PUBLICITY HOUND. SHE SAID I'M
PRETTY RUTHLESS ABOUT GETTING
THINGS DONE I WORKED THE SYSTEM
BUT YOU WON'T ACTUALLY SEE ME
BECAUSE I'M DOING IT. AMONG THE
HIGH PROFILE BILL SHE AUTHORED-
MEASURES DEFINED CAREER ORIENTED
HIGH SCHOOL ACADEMIES TO BAN
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN FLAME
RETARDANTS. AND IMPOSED A NO
LEAD STANDARDS FOR DRINKING
WATER PIPES AND FIXTURES BECAUSE
HER CITY OF OAKLAND THAT SHE
REPRESENTED HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST LEAD CONTAMINATION RATES
AMONGST CHILDREN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WILMA WAS ALSO KNOWN
AROUND THE CAPITOL FOR HER LOVE
OF LITTLE THINGS SUCH AS LONG
NAPS NEW YORK TIMES CROSSWORD
PUZZLES AND GET DIAPER
CHOCOLATES. WHEN SHE WAS TURNED
OUT LIKE I MENTIONED SHE RAN
AGAIN FOR THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WAS ELECTED. AND SERVED A NAP
UNTIL HER UNTIMELY DEATH. HER
MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS ON THAT
BOARD INCLUDED BEING
INSTRUMENTAL IN SAVING SAN
LEANDRO HOSPITAL FROM CLOSURE.
FOR PUSHING TO ENSURE THE
ALAEDA COUNTY WAS FIRST IN LINE
FOR TOBACCO TAX MONEY TO HELP
FUND PROGRAMS FOR PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN. AND WORKING TO EXPAND
IN SCHOOL HEALTH CLINICS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN SHE LED THE
EFFORT TO PUT A BALLOT MEASURE
ON THE BALLOT IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION FOR
LITTLE CHILDREN. AND FOR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH PROGRAMS
ALAMEDA COUNTY VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY APPROVED IT AT
THE TIME OF HER PASSING WILMA
WAS THE ONLY WOMAN ON OUR-
ALAMEDA COUNTY BIRD OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE ONLY ASIAN
AMERICAN. SHE WAS A POWERHOUSE
IN THE BAY AREA'S ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND A LEADER IN
MENTORING AND SUPPORTING AN S.
S. FIRING. API POLITICAL LEADERS
. IN A PRINTED NEWSLETTER
DISTRIBUTED AT WILLIS MEMORIAL.
THE ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN LABOR
ALLIANCE SAID HER LEADERSHIP AND
HER EFFORTS TO UPLIFT IMMIGRANTS
CHILDREN WOMEN AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS WILL NOT BE FORGOTTEN BY
THOSE WHO SHE IMPACTED WITH HER
PERSEVERANCE. TO ADDRESS
SOCIETY'S STRUCTURAL RACISM AND
HER FIGHT FOR EQUITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. HE NEVER ENVISIONED
GROWING UP THAT SHE WOULD BECOME
A PUBLIC ELECTED PUBLIC OFFICIAL
BAND IF YOU SEE THE VIDEO THAT
WAS ON HER COUNTY WEBSITE. SHE
SAID IN IT I DON'T THINK I WAS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO IT. BUT
THEN SHE MET MANY PEOPLE WHO
ENCOURAGED HER TO RUN AND SERVE
THEY TOLD HER YOU HAVE A PASSION
FOR THIS WE NEED YOU TO
REPRESENT US. AT HER MEMORIAL
LAST MONTH HER SON DARREN CHAN
SAID. OUR MOM ONCE SAID. HER
LEGACY WAS TO MAKE. LIFE A
LITTLE BETTER FOR PEOPLE LESS
FORTUNATE. AND THAT'S WHAT A
MEANINGFUL LIFE IS ONE LIVES NOT
JUST FOR ONESELF BUT FOR ONE'S
COMMUNITY IT IS CLEAR MORE THAN
EVER THAT WILMA CERTAINLY
FULFILLED HER LEGACY. AND WE ARE
ALSO VERY FORTUNATE THAT SHE DID. SYNERGY FOR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT WOULD JOIN WITH MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
SHARE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. JUST
ADDING A FEW REMARKS I WAS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH IN TWENTY ONE
OR TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO. TO WORK
WITH WILMA SHE WHO WAS. AT THE
TIME WE MADE HER THE MAJORITY
WHIP OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SUBSEQUENTLY UNDER MISTER WESSON
. BECAME THE MAJORITY LEADER
BECAUSE OF HIS SKILL SET SHE WAS
PART OF THE LEADERSHIP TEAM. AND
WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE VOICES
THAT WE SEE IS ARE AMONG OUR
COLLEAGUES ALWAYS YOUR HOMEWORK.
SO SUBTLE. THE SUGGESTION WAS
ALWAYS PASSIONATE. AND NOT
SOMEBODY TRY TO GRAB ATTENTION
AND HEADLINES BUT SOMEONE WHO
JUST WANTED TO GET THE WORK
DONE. I WAS SUCH A HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY THAT SHE PASSED SO
YOUNG. AND HOW SHE PASSED SHE
WAS A GREAT FRIEND. A GREAT
LEADER. AND A GREAT VALUE TO ALL
OF US HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO ENJOY THE JOURNEY IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
LIKE TO- WHICH JOIN MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM BERKELEY AND IT'S
VERY MEMORY OF WILMA CHAN- I HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HER AS
A PEDIATRICIAN BEFORE I WAS IN
THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE SHE WAS
SUCH A GREAT CHAMPION FOR.
CHILDREN BUT SHE'S ALSO SHE'S
ALSO BEEN A HUGE CHAMPION FOR
THE API COMMUNITY ENDS TEAR THE
ACL LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WERE
RECOGNIZED FOR MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS- NOTED BY- MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM BERKELEY SHE
WAS THE FIRST- API- ASIAN TO GET
ELECTED TO THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- SHE
ACTUALLY RAN ON THE ISSUE OF
REPRESENTATION. FOR API IN IN
THE COUNTY. HE THEN- RANDY DOT
ENTERED THE ASSEMBLY ONE
ELECTION TO THE ASSEMBLY WHERE
SHE'S ACTUALLY WON THE FOUNDING
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND SERVES AS THE VICE
CHAIR. SO WHEN WE FINALLY WERE
ABLE HAVE ENOUGH API LEGISLATORS
HAVE A CAUCUS SHE WAS WONDERFUL
SHE WAS SHE WAS THERE- SHE ALSO
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER AS THE
FIRST. NOT ONLY THE FIRST WOMAN
THE FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR AND THE
FIRST ASIAN THE SERVICE MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY- SO
SHE'S SOMEONE WHO HAS- BROKEN-
MANY BARRIERS AND GLASS CEILINGS
BUT SHE NEVER FORGOT WHERE HE
CAME FROM. WHICH IS ALWAYS A
TREMENDOUS CHAMPION FOR PEOPLE
WHO- FOR CHILDREN FOR IMMIGRANTS
FOR. DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OF COMMITTEES OF COLOR- SHE
BRINGS SHE- CERTAINLY BRINGS A
HUGE LEGACY- AND- CERTAINLY'S-
SHE- THIS MENDEZ LSS FOR THE
API COMMUNITIES. WITH THEIR
TRAGIC LOSS- BUT- APPRECIATE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO TURN IN HER
MEMORY AND- WE WORK TO CONTINUE
HER LEGACY. AND IF A LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THEN TIRES SENATE- JOINED JUNE
ERIN ARE. GOVERNMENT IS TO A
TREMENDOUS TRAILBLAZING PUBLIC
SERVANT AND LEGISLATORS ARE BAD
IN THE PERSON OF. THE WOMAN
CHANNEL ASSET THE NAME BE
BROUGHT FORTH SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED- MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
WE HAVE LISTENERS WILL MOAN.
SHE'S PREPARED. THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO PULL THE FOLLOWING OFF
THE INACTIVE FILE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SIXTEEN S. B. FIVE FOUR
TWO AND FILE ITEM P. EIGHTEEN S.
B. FIVE FOUR THREE THANKS TO
THIS ONE. MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS
TO TEST IS CLEAR. WELL THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES-
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK WITH ALL
OF YOU A TRULY DESPITE- THE WEEK
IT HAS BEEN AN AS WE CONTINUE TO
BATTLE SO MUCH. IN THE WAY OF
THIS VIRUS- BUT AGAIN- IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU ALL AND TO BE BACK
TOGETHER IN THE WAYS THAT WE
CAN. I WISH YOU SAFE TRAVELS AS
WE HEAD HOME FOR THIS WEEKEND
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
NEXT WEEK. AND WITH THAT- AND
CERTAINLY THE EMOTIONAL
FAREWELLS WE GAVE TODAY TO A
NUMBER OF OUR- INCREDIBLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OUT BOTH HERE
IN THIS CAPITAL- A PUBLIC
SERVICE AND OUR CONSTITUENTS.
WITH THAT MR PRESIDENT LET ME
SAY THANK YOU- FOR. ODD TODAY
AND PRESIDING. AND OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY JANUARY TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS TILL THREE
THIRTY WHICH TIME ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MAY. WILL
RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM
THANK YOU.